second drafts are really important
friend of mine once said about me that I
don't write scripts I rewrite scripts
and here's what he meant in the process
of writing the first draft by the time
you get to the end you've sort of
discovered what the movie is about
because it may not end up that first
draft being about what you thought it
was going to be about when you started
writing it you plotted a course to go
due north but as you were going you
started going a little bit east and then
a little bit more East and and when you
end up you're you're going Northeast so
you figured out what the script is about
it's probably fat it's probably long go
back to the beginning of the script
start writing it over again peel away
the things that don't have anything to
do with your story you're going to
discover that a problem that you have in
the third act isn't really in the third
act it's because you didn't set it up
properly in the first so second drafts
retype the whole thing get it down to
its fighting weight that's what I do
anyway